[Musique]
le lycée saint-exupéry de saint dizier
1688 élèves qui ont décidé de même
l'année dernière de mener une campagne
contre l'alcool is
pour cela ils ont commencé par
constituer un club de réflexion qui a
été le premier en france à organiser une
enquête en envoyé un questionnaire à
tous les élèves du lycée 67% d'entre eux
pensent que la consommation d'alcool est
en plein développement chez les jeunes
avez vous déjà été ivres 9 % des lycéens
de 16 à 18 ans avoue avoir déjà été dans
cet état plus de dix fois prise de
conscience justement au bout de ce
problème qui est presque même fléau pour
certains jeunes et on voit même au lycée
des jeunes qui arrivent n'accueille
après-midi le temps libre absolument
dans un état lamentable
je crois que le milieu familial peut
entraîner en gendre et l'alcoolisme mais
autrement
au lycée je pensais plutôt pour ses
ventes et il a beaucoup qui boivent le
mercredi qui raconte après le royaume
pourquoi ils ont bu sont très content et
je crois que c'est ça ça il faut
combattre ça c'est l'exploit partir du
moment où je crois que l'alcool le tabac
enfin je crois que ça rapporte pas mal
d'argent à l'état donc évidemment la
vente est libre quoi je crois qu'avant
tout ça vient d'un autre que celui qui
boit parce qu'il a des problèmes de
problèmes sociaux ou autre chose il sait
pas de son propre choix
c'est un recours à son problème et c'est
pas accepter d'en sortir c'est toi d'une
manière discrète ou à avoir à l'idée si
s'aperçoit qu'il n'est pas seul mais qui
la découvre qu'il a du coup pas qu'il a
quelqu'un qui pense à lui
et puis qui veulent en sortir je pense
qu'il y ait faute cohérente
c'est pas un procès je crois alors quels
sont les jugements on peut apporter
moi je propose que toi déjà fait des
campagnes a déjà fait des dessins une
sensibilisation certaines vous plaît de
faire autour de homs est censé lyon
c'est vrai qu'un jour moi je pense du
bois parce qu'ils s'ennuient savent pas
quoi faire donc je parlais des activités
les occupaient les coûts les occuper
faire quelque chose bombe a créé
carrément une cafétéria et oui sans
alcool c'est prévu à la fin de chaque
séance les élèves du club
commente à leurs camarades les affiches
qui ont été réalisés
les bernois se ramassent à la pelle les
souvenirs et les regrets aussi il ya
toujours l'euphorie du moment avec
toutes les illusions valorisation autre
chose mais le le valais pas toujours gai
c'est une chanson très connue qui se
retrouve dans toutes les grandes
réunions les formations son bord il est
des nôtres il abuse au vert comme les
autres mais finalement on prend ça à la
rigolade à la légère mais ça peut
devenir très très très mobile très très
dangereux et ça ça peut aller à aller
jusqu'à la mort
on a voulu montrer que l'alcool
finalement c'est ça rendait absolument
pas libre et qu'au contraire on a veillé
y avait une dépendance du corps et que
l'alcool est que ces perdait totalement
sa liberté à cause de l'alcool et en
plus ils pouvaient nuire à la liberté
des autres
les plaines comme celui ci commence à se
développer dans toute la france à
marseille à dijon à epinal à versailles
des adolescents mène de plus en plus de
campagnes pour sensibiliser leurs
camarades et même les adultes aux
dangers de l'alcool
[Musique]